because you're not the only one boss
it's not it's not your fault you're not
at fault here you just and then here i
am like just giving you like yeah look
at the panel you talk about the panel
like look
so
how you think i feel like being that i
was on the panel
i feel like
a small part of me is feeling like i'm
carrying a flag for that right and then
another part of him is like you'll stay
away from that [ __ ] you understand what
i'm trying to say but you
want to know because you think the fans
want to know so you dragged me into that
you get where i'm coming from
i think the fans would want to know
about that day fans don't give a [ __ ]
about that man that [ __ ] has been on
youtube yeah but but it's not it's not
about it's not about that video it's
about like yo what's the like yo tell me
about that night you know what i'm
saying like i think people yeah but i
don't really want to remember that
[ __ ] night like if you want to keep
it all the way above that [ __ ] there's
so much [ __ ] that's happened in my life
like like that [ __ ] is like a it's just
another totally get it but at the same
time like
i wasn't even like i said what would i
say when you brought that up i brought
it up
i remember there was love no yeah i did
say that yeah but i also said that toray
you know he did the sign offs and there
was no percentage kickbacks if i got a
percentage kickback on that
i probably remember it a whole lot
better that's real you see what i'm
trying to say so let's let's let's be
you know what i mean let's be let's be
pragmatic about what we're talking about
here man because i don't even like doing
interviews because every the narrative
they always grab the net and it's always
somebody just slower than me you know
what i'm saying that grabs the narrative
and takes it and goes somewhere else
with it and then i end up in the middle
and i end up being a bad guy when all
i'm trying to do is
just like the kaiju record i'm trying to
i'm trying to keep something afloat here
while i'm trying to assist or help you
know what i'm trying to say right
it's always been like that and it just
seemed like rap you know what it seems
like to me man yeah and i'm gonna see
this one shut up about it yeah it seems
like rap is the death
of us
rap is the death of us bro you know what
something say like the artists that come
out and they make their music
and they're impactful
and they're you know there's some good
in them and they're out there and
they're making a difference for the
better
rap is the death of them
not something else but rap
[Music]
i mean also literally and and
figuratively as well because i mean
we've seen that's what i mean yeah
that's what i'm saying and that's a
goddamn shame